so it is now being alleged and it seems pretty
damn clear that Donald Trump's big powerful
squinting at the camera strong looking situation
room photo that was supposedly taken while
the raid that led to the suicide of ISIS leader
Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi was happening, was a
staged photograph likely taken hours after
the event and that Donald Trump was actually
playing golf when the raid took place. I already
told you that Donald Trump admits to having
told the Russians but not house leadership
about the attack in advance. I also already
discussed how that puts our national security
at risk. It puts our sovereignty at risk.
We don't need to go back to that.
We did that already. Let's just talk about
the picture briefly. My BS detector was going
crazy. As soon as I saw this picture, it seemed
so obvious that this was another element of
Trump trying to recreate Barack Obama's Osama
bin Ladin with the picture from the situation
room with the speech that he gave. And with
all of it, the picture looks completely staged
to anyone with common sense. Everyone looks
like they're posing. It was posted by Dan
Scavino. Scavino is an assistant to Trump,
uh, and director of social media. And of course
the Trumpists ate this up like it was being
spoon fed to them. But then it very quickly
started getting weird. Pete Souza, who is
a photographer, he's been a photographer for
numerous presidents ending with Barack Obama.
Notice that the raid took place at 3:30 PM
Eastern time, Washington DC time, and the
IPTC data on this photograph says that the
picture was taken at 1705, that's 5:05 PM
about 90 minutes, 95 minutes after the raid
took place.
Now put that aside for a second. Just looking
at the picture suggests that it's staged.
You see everyone clearly posed. The picture
is symmetrical. It looks at one of the pictures,
looks like it's being taken in a way that
would actually block the view of everyone
in the room of what it is that they are. Supposedly
they're observing. It looks like a setup.
There's the now infamous picture of Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden taken
during the raid that killed Osama bin Laden
and it actually looks like a real candid picture
with people reacting in real time to what's
going on rather than a staged photo op 90
minutes after the incident is over. Now it's
possible and it's been discussed. That was
the raids still going on more than 90 minutes
later, but the idea that they'd be in that
pose after 90 minutes, late 90 minutes after
the raid ended is strange to say the least,
but then we get more information.
It is now believed that Donald Trump was golfing
at 3:33 PM Washington D C time. The raid was
at three 30 Trump golfing at three 33 how
was he in the situation room watching this
live? There are reports that Donald Trump's
motorcade started coming back to the white
house after 4:15 PM Eastern time. Once again,
suggesting the situation room picture had
to have been staged long after the fact. Now,
in reality, this shouldn't matter because
there are so many things that really do matter
a lot here. Why did Donald Trump tell Russians
before congressional leadership about this
raid? Was this operation legal? Always a question.
When us military operations are happening
in other countries, does taking out one person
in ISIS even really matter in the fight against
ISIS since it is cell based and decentralized
and more ideological than about individual
leaders? Does this really undo the damage
that Trump did in the region by pulling troops
from Northern Syria instantly endangering
the Kurds?
There are real issues to talk about, but understand
how numb we've become to Donald Trump's character
that it totally staged room photo is released.
We found out that he was actually playing
golf at the time and we're completely desensitized
to it. I've said before, the further Trump
is from making decisions, it's better. In
a sense. We should be glad that Trump was
nowhere near the situation room when this
raid was happening. His presence could only
have worsened the possible outcomes. If he
wasn't golfing, he might've been tweeting
about it as it was happening, right? I mean,
it's, it's really not good for Trump to be
near these things, but this is just not somebody
who's in it to help the country. This is not
someone who's here to better circumstances
for as many Americans as possible or to be
a participant in this thing. We know as humanity
on planet earth for the betterment of as many
people as possible.
He's in it for himself. Golfing, self enrichment,
staging a picture that he thinks makes him
look, look good, even though the picture is
obviously staged, it's sick and geopolitically,
the most serious thing, and I mentioned this,
but it's really where the focus of our conversation
should be killing leaders of terrorist groups
doesn't do that much in 2019 there is an environment
and a geopolitical status quo that foments
the ideologies that lead to things like ISIS.
That's what you need to change. If you kill
a leader or you show up and you get a leader
to kill themselves, and three of their kids
has happened, the number two is promoted and
that's it. And lastly, as a reminder for this
week of gloating by Donald Trump, that I hope
you're ready for, remember what Donald Trump
said back in 2012 Donald Trump tweeted in
2012 stop congratulating Obama for killing
bin Laden. The Navy seals killed bin Laden.
I wonder, I wonder if Donald Trump is going
to apply that exact same logic to what took
place here, particularly since he was golfing
as this raid was being carried out, and his
involvement could only have put the operation
at risk without helping anything at all. Let
me know what you think. I'm on Twitter at
de Pacman. While you're there. Follow the
show on twitter@davidpakmanshowandmakesureyoufollowmeontwitchbecausewearebackthelivestreamsthisweekattwitch.tv
slash
David pack,